into the building until you're told it
is safe to do so please switch off all
mobile things or turn them to silent I
would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have considered to being filmed
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you're also content consenting
to being filmed by the council and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings the webcasting and all
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may recalled
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the press
are not lawfully excluded finally can
members and officers please ensure that
you press the microphone for speaking
and turn it off when you're finished
before I move to the agenda
the deputy monitoring officer would like
to address the council Thank You chair I
thought this would be an opportune
moment to speak to Kansas with you with
regards to the forthcoming
extraordinary council meeting on the
22nd of October where the proposal for
this councils and lane change will be
debated and for the avoidance of any
doubts I just wanted to clarify the
rules around predisposition and
predetermination the legislation sets
out that a decision maker is not to have
taken to have a closed mind just because
the decision-maker has previously done
anything relevant to that decision
that directly or indirectly indicated
what view the decision-maker took or
would or might take in relation to that
matter
however if the
has used too strong language in support
of their view then the legal position is
that the member has approached the
decision with a closed mind and
therefore should not take part in that
decision as this could affect the
validity of that decision I therefore
urge all members to exercise caution
when many making any comments on this
proposal ahead of the meeting avoiding
any strong statements and to ensure that
when you discuss this report at the
extraordinary meeting that you approach
it with an open mind thank you can I
move on today please item 1 apologies
for absence Thank You chair I've
received apology so far from councilors
Busbee Holt and none having any other
apologies Thank You counsel in the sea
hm
councillor Ricardo you sent his
apologies councillor Osborne thank you
madam chairman councillor Adrienne
Osborne sent his apologies he chairs the
Suffolk Association of local councils
and they've got an award evening tonight
and I think several councillors would be
quite pleased after the evening to get
some news so he does give his apologies
thank you declaration of interest by
councilors are there any declarations
thank you
BC 1915 confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 23rd july 2019 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
that curacy any comments fine and could
I have a proposer then for the Thank You
councillor beer and a seconder please
thank you cuts award all those in favor
please show your hands
that's unanimous thank you
item 4 BC 1916 announcements from the
chairman and leader I refer you to paper
BC 1916 for noting I'd also like to
highlight something that's going on in
Hadley on the 5th of October Hadley on
show is going to be a very large
community event which I'll be opening as
chairman and I'm on the committee I
would like to invite all members along
to this event if you're able to come
we'd be delighted to welcome you so
thank you for that opportunity
cuts the ward have you anything to
report
Thank You chairman yes I know that there
is often a lot of criticism about what
this council does much of it unfair but
we do often get things right and go
above and beyond in order to do things
for our communities as I'd like to let
you know about three recent success
stories on Saturday seventh of September
the first ever sub result festival was
held to showcase this important industry
for Sudbury the largest silk Centre in
the UK the centerpiece of this was the
silk stories film produced by team led
by Bebo this had a private showing the
previous evening for an invited audience
including many of the workers in the
industry and who took part in the film
and councillor Davis and I were there to
represent the council the film was an
excellent production and I must give my
thanks to all involved the weaving
company's Gainsborough's house Sudbury
Town Council Sudbury library but
particularly to the project team led by
Zoe ban Thorpe and Carol Chrissie and to
the film producer Paul pres we were also
lucky to have had the expertise of a
talented young professional filmmaker
council Newman's son Dan who was help
from pupils from the Thomas Gainsborough
School and almost an academy created a
very informative and interesting film
counselors beer and Grandin recently
hosted the Sudbury branch of the Royal
Air Force Association here at endeavor
House giving them a tour of the building
and arranging for some of our officers
to give a presentation of the planning
process showing how democracy works at a
local level the president of the branch
has written a very grateful letter of
thanks for what was the very enjoyable
and informative visit the free swimming
for Under 17's in Sovereign Hadley over
the summer holiday period has been a
great success twelve percent of Under
17's in the district registered 1525
registered in Sudbury and there were
three thousand two hundred and
eighty-eight attendances in Hadley there
were three hundred and ninety three
registrations in 1205 attendances there
is money remaining which will be used to
run the program a half term this really
is a great testament to the hard work of
castle Davis
Cassandra Clements and others in the
team and also a b.call for leisure for
working with us on this a couple of
other points I've been asked by officers
to remind everyone that equality and
diversity training courses are being run
to date the update has been
disappointing and there are plenty of
spaces on the next one on Monday the
30th of September at 2:30 so please do
take advantage of this and finally on a
more somber note I am sorry to announce
that there have been two recent leaks to
a member of the public in Long Melford
one of a draft council document and
another about yesterday's member
briefing on Bellevue yesterday's
incident although I suppose not
technically a leak has a resulted in a
highly inaccurate post online
accompanied by a libelous accusation
against me personally the consequence
has been a ramping up of the already
extreme abuse and vitriol directed at me
we don't want to get to the stage where
advanced information about some topics
can no longer be given to members
frankly it beggars belief that anyone
here has so little respect for this
council and can act in such an
irresponsible and childish manner Thank
You general
Elsevier thank you madam chairman
disappointed to hear that council award
because I'm thought I was one of those
members that were present here yes I
think there's only 12 or 13 others and
obviously you're quite right to say what
you've said but that doesn't you know it
can be any one of us I can assure you in
all honesty it certainly wasn't me
because I wouldn't even know how to
operate you to face broth or Twitter or
any of the others I don't go there but
whoever it is it's a great disrespect to
this council and he should not happen
thank you
Thank You councillor beer cuts them off
easy
thank you thank you madam chairman as
the district councillor representing
long Melford I am standing here before
you all to assure you that I did not
leak any such thing I am known for my
integrity and I'd wish it noted thank
you madam chairman Thank You chairman
can I propose we move to the next item
art I really don't want to hear every
counts for standing up denying that they
leak something
okay thank you
we're going to move to item five now to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with council procedure rules
Thank You chair please be advised that
we had received the following validated
petitions 20 valid signatures regarding
planning applications DC 1901 4 2 2 and
DC 1901 4 2 7 DC 1901 4 to 8 in viewers
and 20 valid signatures regarding
planning application B 14 0 1 1 0 3 and
subsequent applications relating to the
slaughterhouse site in viewers these
will be dealt with through the normal
planning application process thank you
item 6 questions by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
none received chair thank you item 7
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules non receive
chair thank you item 8 to receive
reports from cabinet members I would
like to invite councillor Ward to
introduce this item Thank You chair
you've got before you the regular
reports from all of the cabinet members
these reports cover that the the last
few months for each of the portfolios
and you've had a chance to read through
the reports and this is your opportunity
to ask any questions on the reports of
the cabinet members relevant officers
are also here to provide background
information as and where necessary Thank
You chairman thank you so see mu-1
cabinet member for assets and
investments are there any questions to
this cabinet member
there are no members no questions I'll
proceed see mu-2 cabinet member for
Communities are there any questions
Thank You councillor Hinton thank you
madam chairman just a it's a comment
rather more than a question although it
could be used as a question it's just
that on this report and several of the
other reports there seems to be a 50/50
split almost between comments about what
is going on in mid Suffolk and what is
going on in Weber if the cabinet member
represents mid Suffolk as well then I
could understand it but as the cabinet
member represents Weber why do we have
to have items relating to mid suffix
activities in all of these reports I
understand from the cabinet member for
planning that it's useful to give us a
comparison but no player doing in terms
of housing achievements more the rest of
it and I can understand that but quite
honestly I am not that interested in
what happens at Watterson will Isham
village hall and what's happening with
the kids being in a silver band and
birds other items which appear in here
under the protections councillor davis
is there anything you'd like to say in
reply yeah Thank You chair yeah I
actually totally agree with their
council hints and I think it's a waste
of our paper in the waste of the
councillors time going through all this
I have spoken to the assistant director
for communities and I think we'll see a
different looking paper coming forward
in the future
Thank You councillor Davis any more
questions regarding communities thank
you in that case we'll move on see mu-3
cabinet member for customers digital
transformation and improvement are there
any questions
if there are no questions we'll move on
to see mu4 cabinet member for economic
growth are there any questions please
councillor Hinton thank you madam
chairman
just a quick point in that under the old
MPP F it's 80 that development will be
jobs led we can see that there is a
figure in the IMF annual monitoring
report that 60 percent of new homes are
being built are in rural areas
that's called hinterland villages how
many jobs have we created in those
locations and what he would investment
have we got as the leader has actually
gone on radio and said that the name of
the council is important for identifying
where it is and how we get in with the
investment belief the counts are
responsible for this paper isn't here
today caps award would would you like to
speak to this or can I ask an officer I
think we'll come back with a formal
response later councillor Hinton thank
you any more questions on this paper
okay in that case we'll move on to see
mu5 cabinet member for environment
are there any questions in that case if
there are no questions regarding
environment we'll move on to see mu6
cabinet member for finance are there any
questions
so there are no questions to the cabinet
member for finance
cm7 leader and cabinet member for law
and governance are there any questions
thank you there appear to be no question
so sorry
that's the Hinton very well they was
there but I was just checking something
on the previous report just a quick one
on the joint legal team at some deadens
Berea believers where their base have we
sorted out the capacity problem Jeff but
in terms of staff recruitment etc down
there because there still seems to be an
enormous backlog in trying to get
enforcement action input in particular
implemented the chief executive is going
to answer this so there are no capacity
issues within the legal services team
you're absolutely right based in boasted
Evans Park now of West Suffolk so that
service provides both for West Suffolk
Council and for our two authorities they
have reconfigured to the the legal
services team since it was first created
as a shared service must be some three
or four years ago now that doesn't mean
that they won't continually evolve and
look at what services are needed as and
when demand dictates the type of legal
services they're required but if a
members are interested we can get an
updated report to you specifically about
that service area and bring that forward
if that would be beneficial mr. Hinton
did you want to if I could just come
back on that amount Jim yes it's because
there was a particular case within my
own Ward where the officer could or the
legal representative concerned left the
council the work wasn't allocated for
anybody else and for over a year it's
sacked somewhere God knows where with
nothing happening to it and it wasn't
until I raised it but it was actually
dug out of the woodwork wherever it
happened to be manned that was
supposedly being acted upon but nothing
much has happened yet so they working
extraordinary slow manner when you
consider what their Supreme Court's done
in the last week or so then that's a
different people together the other
point I would just like to make is just
quick comment and that was at the last
District
elections there was a problem in certain
polling stations with the capacity of
the polling boxes as we have got a
potential election coming up within the
next X number of months whatever it
happens to be can we make sure that
holding boxes do have sufficient
capacity and it doesn't require
something sitting there with a ruler a
failing paper because there's no doubt
going to be a lot more parties on the
list and nor what have been in the past
the to fix X it will extend speak on
this I think that's another one for me
as returning officer yes I think I'm
working on the basis of weeks rather
than months in terms of general election
we don't have an issue in terms of
capacity of the of the ballot boxes but
clearly for a general election we would
expect a higher turnout and we will make
sure that we have adequate capacity as
we did for the for the last general
election as well and it may seem
slightly antiquated but much like the
stubby pencil on our bit of string the
ruler to push in the ballot papers into
the box is a commonly accepted practice
up and down the country to make sure
that the folded piece of paper that
maximizes in outer space because
otherwise we could have a lot of boxes
we're not very many ballot papers in
them so yes that is that is common
practice but we will make sure
inevitably that we make we have
sufficient capacity councillor Dawson
she's done that speak if I'm just
wondering in light of the electoral
registration here 3.2 whether that date
can be brought forward the revised list
because perceive the information we
actually have now so the the date of the
publication of the register is it is
prescribed to us but following changes
several years ago now the way in which
the registration scheme works is that
actually it's a rolling scheme so you
will be familiar with receiving a canvas
the document during the summer which
asks you is all your details still
correct is there honor to add to thee to
the register but actually that process
is there is a fail-safe because
registration takes place throughout the
year and the register is updated on an
annual basis on a monthly basis so it
will be at the point that in the
registration is called that the most
recent register is that is the relevant
one but in terms of the formal
publication that is always at the
beginning of December
if there are no further questions we'll
move on to cmu8 cabinet member for
housing are there any questions we'll
now move on
oh sorry counselor Hinton sorry if I'm
reading all the reports and therefore
coming up with some questions on that
just one quick question based on three
point three on page 55 where we're
talking about a funding success
detective rough sleep sleeping I can't
find anything within the report which
says exactly how many people we have got
who are rough sleepers I know we have a
caravan or a bus or whatever it is that
part's its way on somewhere off to the
bottom end of the shopping Peninsula but
I think they're probably people coming
out of it switch but do we have any
figures as to how many might be rough
sleeping within Baber itself councillor
Osborne on April 2 yeah thank you madam
chairman in Baber we currently have no
rough sleepers there is an influx into
mid Suffolk into Stowe market they've
had a problem we're not sure why we
think they're coming obviously from out
of the district and we're not sure why
that is happening so that's being looked
into but we have actually recently set
up a project for rough sleepers where we
have that funding of 209,000 and some of
that money has gone into an outreach
officer for two days a week to work
share between mid Suffolk and Baber so
we're hoping that we can address this
some of the issues with rough sleepers
is they will not engage with our
officers and that's a real problem and
until they start to engage we could
actually count them as a figure in the
box if you like but even so even if they
won't engage we asked an endeavouring to
go out and talk to them and try and get
their their problems resolved non it man
are there any further questions to
counsel Osborn
cut some a breeze thank you thank you
very much um the rough sleeping have we
heard any over the last two months
please
the issue with rough sleepers is they
come and they go very very quickly and
as I've just said to councillor Hinton
if they don't engage with that with our
officers then we can't help them as a
Cystic as unfortunate as that is though
as I've said before we do go out and
help our best - to work with them um
Gavin I don't know if you've got any
more figures on that for over the last
two months
that's the Mabry yes if if I may come
back on that then thank you I would be
interested in the figures because I
actually had one in great welding field
which I found really strange on Park
Bench opposite the post office who I had
to deal with thank you thank you
any further questions in that case we've
on to see mu9 cabinet member for
planning are there any questions do not
appear to be any questions but I believe
counselor Arthur you would like to say
something just a couple of things most
of them really are just to highlight
items in the report and also to update a
couple of things firstly I will say that
most of you have probably noticed
there's quite a lot of mid Suffolk
information including John Hinton
mentioned it earlier on another report I
just like to say that I included it it
hasn't gone in by mistake I've included
it for two reasons one because I think
the figures are useful for comparison
purposes and secondly because we've got
a joint local plan so I think it
actually is appropriate to include
figures for mid Suffolk as well the
highlighting and updating I'd like to
just bring your attention to paragraph
three point three just to reinforce that
the housing land supplied position for
baby is five point six seven years over
the page at three point four further to
that paragraph just to let you know that
the annual monitoring report for 2018 19
now shows 579 completions for the year
and those of you that
but how far behind we were an angular
completions in the past I hope to
welcome that
moving on to paragraph 311 regarding the
drop in events just to let you know that
I've today got the figures for those
events and across the two districts
there were 811 people who attended the
various drop-in events and lastly
paragraph 312 just to highlight that to
you the cross party members steering
group will be beginning its work next
month and consultation some of those are
already being assessed by officers now
thank you
Thank You councillor Elsie so that now
completes this item and we'll move on
now to item 9 BC 1917 a buffoon scrutiny
committee report I'd like to invite
councillor McCraw to introduce his
report which is relating Thank You chair
with the report before you councillors
contains the report on this worker joint
overview and scrutiny over the course of
the last two months these being July and
August each topic has been given its own
paragraph I'll just briefly run through
those joint compliments comments and
complaints is a process we've been
following for some time the disabled
facilities grant again is a developing
point you will have seen a couple of
cards in your pigeonholes recently for
one particular initiative which we would
wish to see further uptake of
specifically that evolving a small
adaptation grants the committee felt
this to be a positive thing the Gypsy
and traveler issue has been --shelves
because it's already is being done by a
joint member a task and finish group and
we have no wish to duplicate efforts
from elsewhere the staff turnover and
Welfare report attracted some press
notice and I just briefly like to
comment that the report
thing of it that indicated that there
had been a tripling of mental health
problems in Weber and mid Suffolk
Council staff was in my view an
inaccurate use of one statistic taken
from one fraction of that report I
thought it was a disappointing in
analysis of what was actually overall a
positive approach and a positive result
for the general health and welfare of
our staff as it should be and I found it
misleading in 19th of August we
commenced on a project we've been
working on for some time
examining the funding the value and the
impact of the Citizens Advice bureaux
both on our citizens and on our own
council services that process continues
now and as the recommendations will show
you we have recommended setting up a
joint working group I think it has to be
called a task and finish group point of
view of Constitution the West Suffolk
hips which and of course Baber and mid
suffered I've already signed on to this
task force task group whatever East
Suffolk and SCC remained to commit to it
but we are still hopeful that process
continues from now and the five-year
housing land supply update speaks for
itself
where possible I have quoted figures
appropriate to just Bayboro district
ansel but obviously this is a joint
overview and scrutiny committee so we
have to look at everything
housing voids continue to improve to
such an extent that we feel no further
need to have a regular update it's been
getting longer and longer between
updates and since I believe the most
recent figure for Baber is about 16 days
is that correct 16 days avoids time when
we reached a peak of well over 70 it's
been success and finally the changes to
the bin collection routes again speaks
for itself this was asked for by members
we have now carried out that and I will
be reporting on that next month's
meeting in October the meeting took
place on September the 19th and it
wasn't possible to protocols
gather report in such a short time I'm
happy to take any questions on any of
those subjects or either in the meeting
or outside Thank You calcium core for
that very helpful summary any questions
to cut stomach Rob
I to invite councillor Horan to move the
recommendations on the agenda Thank You
councillor our own Thank You chairman
this is my first go at being chair of
joint order and standards and I have to
say that I am quite enjoying it a new
role I was transferred from over Burns
scrutiny after 20 years a great expense
very interested maybe not quite as sexy
but very necessary after all and I do
have officers to back me up should I
need it this is the joint treasury
management report covering the position
at the end of the financial year 2018-19
it provides details of the performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period and confirms compliance with the
council treasury management policy the
report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities including the regulatory
framework economic conditions interest
rate and liquidity risk interest rates
during the year continued at very low
levels even though the Bank of England
rate was increased by quarter of one
percent to three quarters of a cent in
August 18 the UK economy showed that GDP
growth was 1.4 percent year-on-year but
it still faces a challenge and outlook
we are continued to operate in times of
uncertainty which is influencing
sterling and UK markets with the
original EU exit date of 29th of March
now well gone there is still much
uncertainty surrounding the manner of
the UK's departure on 31st of October
maybe this will depend on the approach
taken by the new prime minister and
however the future relationship with the
EU is finalized
there are also global economic
uncertainty whilst the US continues to
be set on a path of trade policies and
10
in particular but with the potential for
this to spill over into wider trade
relationships most notably with the EU
more specifically specifically for our
two councils with regard to banking
activities mid Suffolk operated within
the daily bank account limits there ever
Baber exceeded ours by one day by three
hundred and ninety one thousand this was
a result of a timing of a reef run from
a money market not being returned when
expected each council reduced its
short-term debt Baber by five million
and mis suffered by 11 million both
councils replaced that short-term debt
with long-term borrowing Baber by 10 and
three-quarter million and mid Suffolk by
38.2 million to support the capital
program and a fix rates to provide
longer-term certainty all investment
activities undertaken were in cordons
with the approved counterparty lists
both councils investment activity
including average returns can be found
at Appendix C of the report and
investment by both kennels in funding
circle has reduced as owner allocated
funds have been reclaimed for Baber this
was 208,000 of the 638 k previously
invested and for mid Suffolk it was 219
K down from 642 funds will continue to
be withdrawn as existing loans are paid
off and alternative solutions explored
both councils are compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the year was done so in priority order
of security and liquidity over yield as
prescribed in the treasury management
strategy Thank You chairman
Thank You counselor heron could I have a
seconder please councillor Ward thank
you did you want to speak Thank You
chairman I would just like to say a few
words and this is I know quite a dry
report and as counsel Horan's said not
very sexy it's full of lots of tables of
numbers we in this chamber we often have
debates about what we do for our
residents why we do it
even how we do it but this tells us how
we are able to do it and as such is an
incredibly important document and I do
encourage everyone to really try to get
to grips with it I know it's difficult
but it is very informative and that's
been quite interesting once you do get
into it Thank You Jeremy Thank You
council ward I can now open this up to
question and debate thank you
got it John cancel Hinton's that you
wanting to say something you're looking
for that's not to be not to be in the
count and he takes me a bit longer to
get round these sort of figures all I
would would just say as a comment as
part of the debate is that I hope that
we are watching the money markets fairly
carefully because when we're talking
about every 100 million of debt then
we've got to be a bit careful about what
happens to interest rates because it
makes a big difference to ask and three
payments Thank You councillor Hinton
would anyone else like to comment or ask
a question
cut some mabry and thank you thank you
chairman and I would just like to know
what whether we received a penalty for
going one day over our limit please in
our Lord's account thank you
as far as I know not but I defer to
officers if that's any different I'm
sure why didn't you stand up please yes
as I said I'm sure not but I defer to
officers if it's any different no
Melissa is shaking a head no thank you
any further questions
right in that case can we take a vote
for this report please all those in
favor that's curry thank you item 11 BC
1918 favor cell regulation 62 monitoring
report I would like to invite kelsa
Aarthi to introduce paper BC 1918 and to
move the recommendation in the report
Thank You councillor Aarthi
thank you yes this is going to be quite
brief councillor simply asked to note
the reports and and endorse it for
publication it sets out the latest
position regarding the collection
allocation and expenditure of the
council's infrastructure levy for 2018
19 it provides collection and allocation
related information from 11th of April
2016 to the 31st of March 2019 and
Beiber's regulation 62 monitoring report
for 1819 there's also information about
neighborhood cell allocations to the
31st of March 2019 the sill regulations
require that the council as the silk
electing Authority produces a regulation
62 financial report for each financial
year Appendix A is the beta cell
regulation of 62 monitoring the report
for 1819 so it's something we have to do
and we've done it appendix B is for
information and provides a summary of
the neighbourhood Silla locations made
since charge and came into effect on the
11th of April 2016 and I will just
remind you that all of this and a lot
more data is publicly publicly available
on the website just to add a little bit
information regarding SIL up-to-date and
the size of the figures that we're
talking about for Baber the outstanding
potential Commission's the amount their
totals eleven point four million pounds
of which three and a half million pounds
has already been collected for
implemented permissions and another two
million pounds is due for more recently
implemented permissions and finally just
to remind you that we're going through a
SIL framework review at the moment and
there's a member briefing on that at
5:30 tomorrow afternoon in this chamber
so if you feel that you're not up to
speed with the review or perhaps even
you're not informed enough on silk
generally please come tomorrow afternoon
at 5:30 thank you Thank You Kathy
can I have a seconder please Thank You
councillor Davis so I'd like to open
this up now for questions and debate yes
counselor thank you thank you and I've
just got a small matter as a personal
interest of mine in my ward and as we're
racing through our agenda thought I take
this opportunity can I ask what action
the council would take if a developer is
very slow or late in paying their their
silver they're due to pay would that be
civil action and what sort of time frame
were they would they be given to pay
colossi would you like to answer that
yeah I'm deaf I was desperately looking
around for a little bit of help to
answer that question I don't know if
there's a particular case that you're
referring to I know that there have been
some situations where payments have not
been made on some of the larger
developments that's been quite costly to
the developer because they're they're
phasing is no longer applicable if they
don't make the first payment so they've
had to pay the whole lot up front I
think the best answer is if you can give
me the particular case you're talking
about and and I'll follow it up for you
thank you I believe counsel Mabry did
you have something you wanted to us yes
thank you chairman and looking through
Appendix B which is always good to have
a look to see who's got what monies have
what's allocated what they can take I'm
just a little confused and it's probably
a printing error but looking for the
five parishes in my ward which I hope
can sarathi can answer is I can find
four of them the last one a few from the
bottom are going to say it says Walden
Field Parish Council I'm assuming that's
little Walden Field and it's a printing
error but above it it says corn our
Parish Council and I just like to know
exactly which parishes they are please
thank you
is that a detail that we can answer now
or is that something that would be
better to get back to councillor Mabry
on the normal answer to the question but
they I think that little begins with an
L and great begins with a G so the two
Weldon fields have been different places
however all of the information for all
of the parishes is available on the
website is available on XCOM and I
actually have the pages open here so if
Margaret Mabry would like me to I can go
through all of the relevant but parishes
with her immediately after the meeting
her parishes are of course my parishes -
because we share a reward Thank You
cancer RC Council Mabry did you want to
come back on that yeah um it's just that
I'm looking and I think this says 11
piece parish council and then Lindsey
then long mail fit then something called
odd and something more than filled well
it's supposed to be little Walden field
that should come before long Alfred
thank you
I think counselor I'll see hers offered
to speak to you about this after the
meeting so I think we'll deal with the
detail then thank you any further
questions
councillor Osborn thank you madam chair
it's not a question actually it's a
statement I think this is a really good
news story it's great to see our town
and parish and parishes benefitting from
this money that's coming in their
direction you know if they've got a
neighbourhood plan they get 25% if they
haven't they still get 15% and it's
really doing well and as well as the
bids that they're putting in some have
been successful some haven't I believe
but it's just one of those really good
news stories that I think needs to get
out there and be circulated much more
than it is I know that Sudbury for
example looking at the figures here
they've got a lot of money and they're
using it very effectively and
efficiently so well done to all officers
and members concerned
Thank You counselors born any other
comments or questions
fine in that case if there are no more
comments or questions all those in favor
of the report the recommendations in the
report that's carried thank you so now
we'll move on to item 12 BC 1919
timetable of meetings 20 20 and 21
rather than raising any queries on any
of the dates mentioned in the timetable
any queries should be emailed to the
corporate manager for democratic
services for consideration and brought
back to the council at a future council
meeting I would like to invite council
Awards who introduced paper BC 1919 and
to move the recommendation in the report
thank you Thank You chairman exactly
what it says it is it's the the
timetable of council cabinet and
committee meetings for the municipal
Year 2022 2021 and I just like to
propose the recommendation that this
draft timetable for 2022 2021 be
approved by councils evening thank you
Thank You councillor Ward so could I
have a seconder cuts inaudible and thank
you we're not having a debate then on
this so we're going straight to the vote
those in favor
thank you that appears to be unanimous
thank you now we'll move on to item 13
council appointments I would like to
invite councillor Ward to introduce this
item Thank You chairman it's just one
appointment
we need to appoint a member to the
east-west rail consortium
and councillor Michael Holt as the
cabinet member for economic growth is
going to be appointed to this body thank
you thank you I think we have a second
turn there can't some across thank you
sorry did you want to speak did actually
as well that's quite happy to second it
but I take an interest in rail because
I'm a regular user and Eastern sorry I
apologize coach an east-west
communication in this country has always
been difficult crossing East Anglia it's
not as easy as it should be
can I ask if that's the purpose of the
east-west rail consortium thank you very
much that case I'm more than happy to
continue seconding thank you can we take
a vote on this please thank you let's
carry it now I'll move on to item 14
missional notice I would like to invite
councillor miles easy to move the motion
Council of easy thank you thank you
madam chairman I asked the council do
you see the document before you and it's
one piece of a4 and would you like to
take it as read I believe that the
motion sits alongside the climate change
motion that this council passed the one
goes in hand with the other it's
important that we have a balanced
biodiversity within our community
because it keeps us alive so does
council want me to read through the
elements
you can if you wish but everyone has it
in front of them so it's very mission
fine thank you may have a seconder
that's the Norman thank you did you want
to speak councilman oh yeah thank you
please speak no yes sir thank you madam
chairman and yeah I just wanted to
obviously thank councillor mal Vaizey
for bringing this forward this much mean
needed motion and you know she's correct
obviously the biodiversity in our
communities what keeps us alive and it's
vitally important that we protect that
and especially when it comes to sort of
things around of elements and in
wildlife corridors as well making sure
that there's provision for those and
that we're looking after them in every
way that we can and I believe that the
creation of a wild might of the wildlife
network map which is proposed in this
motion will be really useful for both
the council and residents and as it will
help identify essential wildlife
corridors which will allow us to make
practical informed decisions about these
wildlife corridors and identify where we
could possibly make more and things like
that which I think would be really
useful for the community as it is
something that has been practiced other
councils and so dipswitch who have a big
wildlife corridor map which has been
really useful for me particularly is the
ward member to support on a pinewood as
I'm so close to its which it does
incorporate some of my areas but not all
of them so it would be really useful for
the council as a whole and residents I
also think the trees for life scheme as
well which obviously make sure that we
can keep up with our ever-changing
environment is the district as it is
changing a lot at the moment with a lot
of the house building so making sure
that we keep the fabric of our district
which living in rural Suffolk has always
been very rich and biodiversity I think
it's very important to keep that and so
it gives me great pleasure to see second
this motion and yes just thank you very
much
Thank You councillor Norman councillor
I'll see ya I'd actually like to
congratulate council mile VZ and the
green group on this council for the way
that they work together to arrive at a
suitable form for the pledges in the
motion
thank you check and I just clarify
councillor Jameson will still have to
move the amendment because actually
we're still debating the original and
emotion at the moment cancer Clemson
would you like to move your Amendment if
you still wish to do so yes thank you
Jeff
bringing both July's emergency motion
and the biodiversity motion for the
biodiversity is obviously something
that's often overlooked because of the
climate
everyone concentrates on the permit they
don't think about the Advisory Council
in London mentioned with this motion in
principle we fully support the first
three points and one three we just tell
24 maybe strengthen little bits if we're
going to be serious about the climate
and the biodiversity emergency be a
little bit more specific around what
with money's going to be spent but again
spent on on what we saw with results is
coming from so we've had one point for
slightly in their editor point five
point four we've said the money
specifies where the least resources may
be necessarily and some wording sorry
this is exactly the same wording has
agreed unanimously by me suffolk in july
on their biodiversity motion and point
five
maybe gives us the opportunity to let
allow us to act quickly if an
opportunity arises a bit of land becomes
available we could purchase it we use as
a wildlife in area I can ring the two
amendments or I think everyone's got the
amendments in front of them but perhaps
you'd like to draw members attention to
just the items of change thank you
Thanks
cuts them off easy do you expect a
second effort oh sorry yes sorry I'm
looking for a seconder for the amendment
councillor Horan thank you did you want
to say anything counsel heron present
time madam chairman no thank you
cut some off easy do you accept this
amendment thank you madam chairman I
accept the amendment at item for that
additional biodiversity resources be
provided as necessary to support the
task force provide more input to
supporting planning officers strengthen
the role of the public realm team and
provide advice to parishes and other
community landowners and I and the
additional item five any funding to
maintain and improve the biodiversity of
our area for 2019 2020 will be
recommended to cabinet for approval the
task force would recommend the amount to
be spent in future years in a report
back to cabinet by March 2020 and I
accept those amendments Thank You
councillor fees thank you so now we will
go to debate on the amendments and the
original motion thank you with the
amendments
oh you want me to repeat the final
version which we have in front of us
thank you
beautifully timed Thank You chair but
only one point I wanted to add is it and
it refers to part three of the original
motion and councillor norman referred to
it in seconding the original motion
about the relationship of the tree for
life and it's slightly related it
impacted housing development and in fact
I think it's more related to births and
that's a crucial point it's been a very
successful program in mid Suffolk I
think it's been appreciated and the
great point is that it's an option for
people to take up they don't have to do
it not everybody has a garden available
for them to plant a tree in but a tree
can be planted on behalf of every child
born and it would be good for that to
take place in Weber as it does in mid
Suffolk and I think it's a very nice
motion thank you felt some accrual cuts
the Heron did you want to speak yes
thank you chairman just a question
really
could this be appended to our joint
Local Plan because it does make a
difference to that it affects what you
do in planning corridors I think housing
estates and it's just difficult to have
one without the other I feel it should
almost be written into our emerging
local plan I would feel as it makes
difference in my opinion Oh
cuts in love easy thank you madam
chairman and councillor Horan makes a
very valid point we did make a reference
to the local plan and the need for
planners to bear in mind climate change
on the climate change and I I believe
that these two motions actually go
together chief executive wants to I can
see cats there are feet
quickly leafing through his his copy of
the joint logo plan but but I'll say
what I'll say and then he may well by
which time found what he wants to say as
well so it just in terms of the ability
simply to append to this to the local
plan no only because as you will
appreciate the the developmental local
plan is a ridiculously complicated
process and has to make sure that it
goes through the relevant hoops
however we are as you heard earlier the
close of the the current consultation
phases the local plan and clearly this
can help inform alongside the other
consultation aspects any revisions to
the policies that come forward at the
next stage of the local plans who can
certainly take into account and built in
but had the mechanics in exactly how
that happens will need to be considered
carefully to make sure that we comply
with the processes we need to comply
with in terms of developing local plans
I don't think I've worked long enough
for Aarthi okay yeah thank you for that
the thing that I think I ought to say
mmm is that it's definitely not contrary
to the provisions of the local plan and
if you have a look at policy LP 17 which
is the biodiversity policy it's an LP
policy which is for the determination of
planning applications and in there and I
had it a minute ago now I've lost it I
was no dreadful I should have
highlighted it but anyway it certainly
isn't - contrary to the provisions of
that policy which talks about somewhere
planning positively for the creation
Protection Enhancement and management of
local networks about biodiversity within
wildlife corridors blinking to green
infrastructure networks and areas
identified by local partnerships for
habitat restoration and creation and
there was F its policy LP 17 F the
developments primary objective is to
conserve and enhance biodiversity thank
you
cancer Hinton thank you madam chairman I
agree with what's been said about the
local plan it is important that this is
considered within the local plan the
original mpps had a provision for
protecting existing ancient woodlands
for instance and head roads and isolated
ancient trees and hedgerows which seems
to be missing from the latest version of
the BMP PF and if you chop down an
ancient tree and say well it can be
replaced by some new ones that we're
going to put in doesn't do much for the
carbon footprint for a long long time so
it's important that we maintain what
we've got rather than just move it
around and say well we look at the good
work we're doing by putting in these new
trees if you've taken out some old trees
doesn't help the environment at all and
I know that in one particular
application brings to mind an ancient
oak tree probably couple hundred years
old and an ancient hedgerow that goes
with it are proposed to be taken out
purely because it gives visibility splay
but they will be replaced by new
plantings further back from the road
well yes but it's gonna be a long time
before they contribute anything to
reducing the carbon footprint thank you
any further comment or questions cuts
them off easy did you want to respond to
anything that you've heard this evening
thank you madam chairman um not really I
did read somewhere that we've actually
got more trees now in our country than
before the Industrial Revolution but I
don't have the facts and figures to hand
so thank you very much thank you thank
you
so in that case we'll go to a vote on
the proposal with the amendment can we
take a vote on this please I believe I
believe that's unanimous thank you
so we're coming to the end of the
meeting now the date of the next meeting
is 22nd of October 2019 at 5:30 followed
by the extraordinary meeting at 6:30 so
I now close the meeting thank you all
very much thank you and good evening